si on m'avait dit il ya dix ans quand
j'ai interpellé dans une conférence au
étaient venus sur mon campus où j'étais
étudiant je vais poser une question elle
m'a dit bah vous viendrez mort à la fin
et puis on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
et non seulement je les ai vus j'ai
rencontré jeudi qu'il avait envie de
m'engager elle m'a pris sous son aile et
je sais pas si vous rendez compte parce
qu'on parlait à l'instant de la jeunesse
mois elle a fait de moi
à 28 ans vice président de la première
région d'europe il ya dix ans quand j'ai
rencontré valérie jouve nappe je venais
à peine de devenir français et donc on
va tous ceux qui disent comme parfois on
l'entend chez jean luc mélenchon que la
france est un pays raciste ce genre de
jeu par l'entendre j'ai vécu ça elle m'a
donné cette chance et c'est grâce à elle
vous êtes promesse républicaine elle
peut aussi exister sage oublierai jamais
je n'oublierai jamais parce que
en plus ce jour là je vais interpeller
sur un sujet de m'a dit je vais faire le
nécessaire et elle me l'a dit elle l'a
fait et moi je veux témoigner de sa
aussi parce que ça fait dix ans que je
la vois faire ce qu'il dit et c'est vrai
on vient d'apprendre à l'instant avec la
malle des gens un doute maintenant sur
la capacité des politiques d'agir il y
en a une quand il dit quelque chose elle
le fait et moi j'ai vraiment vécu ça
avec elle et elle a m'a donné ma chance
parce que j'avais envie de m'engager
parce que j'avais l'amour de la france
parce que je trouve que ce pays
magnifique je suis devenu français mais
s'il n'y avait pas eu valérie je serai
pas aujourd'hui engagé en politique elle
m'a confié la responsabilité du groupe à
la région c'est pas n'importe quelle
responsabilité est un groupe de 80 élus
sur j'en était le benjamin le plus jeune
j'en suis devenu le président parce
qu'elle l'a voulu vous connaissez
beaucoup de politiques qui prendrait ce
risque c'est pas les élus qui manquait
ça a été une prise de risque une audace
incroyable de sa parole c'est bien tout
ce que vous êtes bon tout simplement pas
vivre rien ah oui j'ai malien mais j'y
viens cette école
c'était pas du casting c'était pas du
chiqué c'était pas du casting c'est du
repérage de talent parce qu' il fallait
aller chercher les talents c'est
exactement ce que je voulais dire c'est
que c'est quelqu'un qui est ça s'est vu
à l'instant j'espère elle ne juge pas
les gens en fonction de leur origine ou
de leur apparence ça y est un candidat
dans cette élection présidentielle qui
s'appelle eric zemmour et qui en gros
vous explique que si vous n'avez pas le
bon prénom ne pouvait pas être un bon
français je vous en avez d'autres comme
jean luc mélenchon qui au contraire
utilise un peu c'est sûr qu'au d'origine
pour en faire une boutique électorale
pour en faire un électorat captif bien
le juge les gens sur leurs actes sur
leurs mérites sur leur travail et je
crois qu'on a besoin de ça aujourd'hui
dans notre pays c'est sûr ottomane
serait pas passé qui s est pas dans le
calendrier c'est pas d'anciens
mais voilà mais je pense que ce qu'il
faut maintenant c'est qu'on est
effectivement une président de la
rythmique qui fait ce qu'elle dit qu'ils
considèrent que la jeunesse c'est pas
une population à la calypso un cheikh
othman pourquoi alors valérie là ce soit
et j'en ai parlé de démission pourquoi
on s'envoie là on sent on sent que vous
vous la connaissez bien vous en parler
mais les français n'imaginent pas
valérie pécresse comme vous vous en
parler pourquoi mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout est fait pour qu'on
les détournent de cette élection non
mais voilà on n'y a pas que ça bah y'a
quand même axa ils ont regardé des
différentes émissions et bahia blanca et
là j'espère que ce soir ils vont le
ressentir mais ce que vous dites là les
français ne le ressentais pas pourquoi
mais je vous donne un exemple précis
parce que aujourd'hui on a un président
de la république qui
distribue beaucoup de chats elle a dit
tout à l'heure à nadine morano elle a
dit un truc elle a dit il a à chaque le
président de la république valéry est-ce
que vous je vous parle franchement
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas trop franche
vous dites vraiment les choses quand
vous dites ça on pourra pas le faire ça
c'est pas possible je peux pas faire
rêver les français très important ce que
me dit cielo y c'est très important
parce que le problème c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui une dette colossale double
dette écologique et financière double
dette et on l'entrée de la léguer à nos
générations futures et tout le monde
s'en fiche c'est pas un débat de la
campagne planète au soin passe à la
trappe aujourd'hui emmanuel macron roux
devrait valérie pécresse mais c'est un
pendant deux mois je vais vous dire
leggett des toits dylan une génération
et rassure je vais vous parler comment
on faisait la malle futur qu'il a
correctement ne comprends pas ça les
fronts c'est inouï si mes séries
beaucoup prennent et son jeu
si
ça c'est la vérité ça parle ou par mail
à nous tous on vous dit que tous les ans
les ados qui sont faits aujourd'hui
toutes les agences toutes les débats
avaient fait les jeunes c'est les
nouvelles oui mais oui mais oui mayenne
matrone contrat doit dépenser
aujourd'hui demain othman je la seule
quel courage de le dire eh oui mais
c'est oui justement est-ce que valérie
pécresse ne devriez pas plus mentir
mais non parce que justement c'est tous
âges entre élus je vais être élu parce
que moi je sais que les français ils
sont très politique et je sais qu'à un
moment donné ils vont rentrer dans cette
élection
oui oui ils vont se dire qui est ce qui
nous dit la vérité et pièces qui aura le
courage de réparer ce pays qu'est ce que
à quoi je les casser les ghettos qui est
ce qu'ils en parlent des quartiers
populaires aujourd'hui dans cette
campagne à part jean luc mélenchon mais
jean-luc mélenchon c'est l'art c'est
parlons chez moi c'est celle de la
clientèle 1 c'est je vous promets tout
elwes medulla sont scellées lui monsieur
250 milliards il n'a pas l'argent pour
le faire donc il ne fera pas moi je
jouerai l'argent et je le ferai comme à
la région ile de france et je voudrais
que les français alors c'est vrai que
les français il ya eu la crise qu vite
j'étais d'été un peu enfermé dans ma
région une connaissent moins en dehors
de la région mais ça c'est pour ça aussi
que je viens avec quelques témoins qui
peuvent résoudre manne pour finir parce
qu'on va conclure là dessus est ce que
vous y croyez vraiment un mais j'y crois
dur comme fer mais comment je vous le
dis franchement ça se fait mais parce
que on n'a pas le choix on a appris
enfin si on continue comme ça on va dans
le mur regardez les gens sont contents
aujourd'hui dumas qui le fait tant de
fois qu'il
aimerait qu'on dise oui vous êtes un
déjeuner avec un pote voilà 22 points on
est quelques saint louis
vous dites vraiment senti trader on voit
dans tous les déjeuners dans tous les
dîners les gens qui parlent des
élections les élections même s'ils
disent et intéresse de moins on le voit
les audiences à la télé les émissions
l'intéressent demande moi parce que dans
la tête des gens ces jouets emmanuel
macron serait président qu'est ce que
vous dites à sarir il les gens et c'est
vrai en train d'ouvrir les yeux arrêté
non mais je vais vous dire pourquoi il y
en a je la connais depuis dix ans c'est
une combattante mais qu'est ce que vous
avez dans le rang après six modèles
c'est au tour ce qu'on vit là ces
débauchages individuels ces tentatives
de déstabilisation ça la renforce elle
est capable de créer la surprise parce
que encore une fois on peut pas
continuer comme aujourd'hui je vous le
dis a de quoi qu'il en coûte c'est pas
possible c'est le couac il nous coûte
c'est pas finot et et vous allez
manuel macro on repasse 50 a commandé
six repasse cinq ans et qui nous refait
ce qu'il a fait sur ce quinquennat c'est
une catastrophe pour le pays moi je peux
pas croire qu'après tout ce qu'on a vécu
sur ce quinquennat aka président de la
république qui dit qu'il faut
déconstruire l'histoire de france capa
de culture française moi ça me choque un
cas présent de la république de mon pays
pour qui suis devenu français disent
qu'il n'y a pas de culture française où
il faut déconstruire l'histoire neutre
les choses
qui vont avoir le courage de prendre les
bonnes décisions pour l'avenir du pays
pour la jeunesse pour les nouvelles
générations parce que 1000 milliards de
dettes en un an ça veut dire qu'un
enfant qui n'est aujourd'hui la 45000
euros de dettes sur la tête vous trouvez
ça bien cyrille pourquoi que les
français vont réélire ce système là
eumelio mon avis oui mais ben non je n'y
crois pas je me jeunes musiciens et la
non mais cyril hanouna moi je pense une
chose je pense que les français ils sont
libres ils sont totalement indépendants
ils sont frondeurs mais il n'aime pas
les matches écrit dan ans donc quand on
leur dit allez amis c'est plié c'est
plié n'allez pas voter classons les
sondages vous ont déjà dit le résultat
de l'élection ça les rend dingue donc
ils vont nous regarder ils vont nous
juger et ils vont se poser des questions
et moi alors c'est vrai que cette
campagne elle est vraiment très très dur
parce que je suis la femme à abattre
nation exemple à droite républicaine
c'est la seule qui peut battre emmanuel
macron non mais c'est vrai c'est ça
c'est la somme c'est un peu la gueule
bah oui mais alors là des torrents des
torrents de boue mais vous savez vous
vous souvenez il y avait alors c'est les
moins de vingt ans ne peuvent pas trop
connaître mais il y avait une émission
qui s'appelait les guignols notre show
les guignols de l'info oui et il y avait
une marionnette de chirac assure à
l'époque manger à l'époque et à l'époque
il était vraiment pas du tout favori on
avait décidé que l'élection était pliée
c'était malade y aurait il été
secrètement il allègue le temps et
nicolas sarkozy avec la manière il avait
il avait sauté
mais chirac avait gagné et
monsieur là je finis mais cette
marionnette elle dit elle elle avait
admis qu à chaque fois qu elle prenait
un coup de poignard elle disait à ses
tics ça pique alors c'est vrai que cette
campagne elle pique un peu voilà elle
pique un peu mais il ya une belle phrase
puisque vous aimez nicolas sarkozy une
belle phrase de nicolas sarkozy il dit
pour devenir président de la république
il faut plus avoir une partie de son
corps tient pas une cicatrice et ben moi
mon cas aujourd'hui il est couvert de
cicatrices mais chez une combattante et
ce combat on va le gagner et on va le
gagner à la fin pour le territoire
[Applaudissements]